Максим Сагибгареев: Да,
Игорь А.: ребят, по стратегии партнерской сети, значит, что у нас от вчерашнего обсуждения закрепилось и что принято в целом из вчерашнего обсуждения. Закрепленная рамка – это мы один базовый
Игорь А.: продукт запускаем изначально в партнерскую сеть.
Игорь А.: И он является профориентацией, при этом страна, валюта, язык и состав локальной версии могут быть разными. Почему? Потому что мы на разные рынки можем формировать. Просто мы говорим
Игорь А.: о том, что есть продукт, а дальше это уже его характеристики. Вот. И сразу же зафиксированная рамка, что один продукт не означает одну цену во всех странах. Это мы как раз вчера тоже
Игорь А.: проговаривали про регионы, и это касается и стран тоже. Я считаю, что в одной стране мы должны единую цену ставить, МРЦ, РРЦ, но при этом в разных регионах могут сами партнеры регулировать,
Игорь А.: мы отдаем им это на управление. В разных странах опять же та же ситуация, просто где -то в долларах, где -то в дирхамах и так далее.
Максим Сагибгареев: вот знаешь с товарами есть это всякие скаю и так далее либо так такой же принцип цифровым товаром применим ну конечно только бы мы перепродаем даже не только цифровые мы перепродаем
Максим Сагибгареев: еще и разговоры конкретно с сеансом. Да,
Игорь А.: я тебе рассказывал про SPU.
Максим Сагибгареев: То
Игорь А.: есть SPU это, например, iPhone 17. Может быть, SPU. А iPhone 17 уже может быть произведен во Вьетнаме, произведен в Китае, произведен в США. Иметь там
Игорь А.: 256 гигабайт, 1 терабайт, иметь там, ну, в общем, Pro, Pro Max и так далее. Вот это уже разные SPU, которые имеют разные характеристики
Максим Сагибгареев: связка с пою из каю смотри я не хочу сейчас уходить детали просто чтобы это как бы тоже ну такой часть исследовательскую которую я добавил чтобы ее здесь использовали ну чтобы по аналогии
Максим Сагибгареев: было легко легко это все управлять всеми вариациями и ценой и составом вот и такой еще момент то что если мы продаем через с будем ну там через apple store или счету наш продукт должен
Максим Сагибгареев: быть не полностью цифровым если мы хотим чтобы не весь платеж что комиссия в 30 процентов там не снималась то есть как бы тут тоже в дальнейшем надо ну как будто гибкость она сейчас
Максим Сагибгареев: есть сейчас мы продаем чисто профориентацию один продукт но просто учитывать саму структуру и модель чтобы она тоже то есть партнерская система и вот контроля и учета то что вы делаете
Максим Сагибгареев: просто опережение немножко добавлю я думаю это не сильно увеличить сложности но вот такое такой момент надо учитывать тоже то есть мы сейчас продаем один базовый продукт а сама методика
Максим Сагибгареев: методология партнерская позволяет подавать любые продукты то есть как это мы не тумане до каждый эксперт может рекомендовать продукты каждого эксперта и получается на этом зарабатывать
Вадим Х.: большой и логик варень
Максим Сагибгареев: так
Игорь А.: хорошо давайте я тогда дальше продолжу спасибо за дополнение здесь будут формулы формулы в принципе этом проходился по ним проверял очень интересные правильные вот Ну, они достаточно
Игорь А.: простые.
Игорь А.: MRC – это X, Y, X – это RRC, Z – это сумма MainExpert за единицу. Значит, там еще появится K, а вот партнер назначает K. K – это цена партнера.
Игорь А.: Опять же, мы можем определить, например, для России, какие эти величины сегодня. Я хотел бы как раз -таки, чтобы мы это зафиксировали. Вот, и, соответственно, как решение будет пойти
Игорь А.: к партнерам с этим всем. Так, партнер как основная
Максим Сагибгареев: роль.
Игорь А.: Опять же,
Максим Сагибгареев: вот вчера... Момент, короткий момент по поводу цены, смотри, просто чтобы тоже, ну там не ромка, или как -то мы разобрали немножко кейсы разных противоречий, то есть просто сценарный
Максим Сагибгареев: такой анализ, когда у тебя есть покупатель, и вот эти все цены есть разные. И как бы партнер рекомендует все эти цены, чтобы, ну то есть мы прошлись по чувствительности к рискам, ко
Максим Сагибгареев: всяким, в духе то, что, ну там, этично, неэтично, разные цены человек видит и так далее. Ну, это все может быть, просто чтобы у нас была четкая здесь позиция, и она как бы была защищаемая
Максим Сагибгареев: и устойчивая долгосрочная, и все, вот такая мысль.
Игорь А.: Давайте остановимся здесь. Хороший момент. Вчера я, как пример,
Максим Сагибгареев: большой
Игорь А.: разброс делал между МРЦ и РРЦ. Мы можем этот коридор немного сократить. Зачем это делается? Как раз -таки для разных регионов цена чувствительна.
Игорь А.: Я не думаю, что мы сейчас должны делать МРЦ, РРЦ региональный, мы хотя бы для страны должны сделать, но мы можем его сократить. Мы как раз его можем проговорить и вжать эти рамки, чтобы
Игорь А.: базовый доход у партнера был плюс -минус одинаковый, который отличался бы на 20 -30 % между партнерами за счет скидки, а не в два раза, например, или в три. мы
Максим Сагибгареев: можем и тут важно еще все -таки гипотеза ни одного двух продуктов но это как бы вот мысль да слуха на рыбы может быть не первичная но она позволит тогда то что в регионах будет продаваться
Максим Сагибгареев: продукт просто сам дешевого как бы состава а в крупных городах там не знаю какие москва питер новосибирск такие богатые города домашекатеринбург да то есть ну такие центры вот там может
Максим Сагибгареев: продаваться оба продукта например ну опять же это как мысли в рамках одного продукта ну а какая проблема если бы у нас вот то что ты сейчас сказал мы делаем как ты сейчас сказал да
Максим Сагибгареев: то есть небольшая там градация по цене и у нас один продукт который универсально до подходит под все региону ты об этом
Игорь А.: да вот если мы даем разницу большую давай чуть чуть ниже как раз провисну так для наглядности вот здесь вот есть скажи какая страница
Максим Сагибгареев: номер страница
Игорь А.: 4 а я если что показываю демонстрации для
Максим Сагибгареев: записи
Игорь А.: свободы
Максим Сагибгареев: на станка да вот это да
Игорь А.: как раз партнер выбирает цену весь прирост сверхфиксированная зэк увеличивает его валовую дельту то есть вот как раз таки о чем я говорю что мы можем с одной стороны сильно фиксировать
Игорь А.: разницу между y и x чтобы здесь, например, условные 100 тысяч рублей, которые мы хотим RRC. Сумма Main Experts может быть 50, а МРЦ может быть 80. Но тогда мы, скорее всего, условно
Игорь А.: говоря, в вакууме 10 тысяч это может быть, да там условно говоря 5 8 то есть мы защищаем доход как раз таки слабых продавцов ну им нужно наработать этот опыт но доход они в любом случае
Игорь А.: получают там не 5 тысяч а там 3000 условно говоря и не сильно отрываем цену одну от другой
Максим Сагибгареев: я тебя услышал я тебя услышал и понял у меня к тебе предложение такое методологическое то есть чтобы следующие итерации когда -то запустишь сейчас после разговора был еще раздел сценарного
Максим Сагибгареев: анализа в котором мы можем ну как бы просто синтетически придумать ok у нас есть такой -то учитель нас такая цена 10000 у нас есть такая цена там 20000 и вот эти все три цены то есть
Максим Сагибгареев: сразу же говорим то есть они вложены получаются в этом 100000 ну и пройтись посмотреть окей на разных регионах там продаются какие плюсы какие минусы то есть просто эти сценарии чтобы
Максим Сагибгареев: он несколько раз прогнал его в общей модели как бы как будто вот ну есть эксперт у него есть они на платформу платформы есть классный продукт эксперты продают этот продукт и
Максим Сагибгареев: тогда мы уже увидим конкретно не просто zx и y а уже сейчас можем прийти как раз той задачи который то стоит конкретные цены да а после сценарного анализа смотри что можно сделать можно
Максим Сагибгареев: пойти как саша делает там исследовать рынок или там вас уже какое -то исследование есть и мы видим какие есть цены ну просто сделать таблицу там по крупным региональным центром пройтись
Максим Сагибгареев: не ромка отдельно запускается исследование находит часто занимает там не больше думал она найдет все ключевых поставщиков похожих продуктов и потом сделает медиану по цене среднюю цену
Максим Сагибгареев: и процентили первые пять процентов и последние 95 по цене вот и все это им я на есть и ты можешь тут мы можем определяться то есть как бы где мы хотим быть выше рынка по рынку и мы
Максим Сагибгареев: по стране тоже видим теперь какая -то медиана будет
Александр Бондаренко: ну
Максим Сагибгареев: тогда у нас есть позиционирование конкурентно то есть как бы мы можем вы теперь понимаем хотя бы на примерном приближении данные по рынку понимаем что какой спред по рынку есть даже
Максим Сагибгареев: если допустим не вникать глубоко в продукт потому что тут продукт тоже может меняться но в целом и теперь у нас есть коридор и мы можем конкурировать ценой либо не конкурировать ценой
Максим Сагибгареев: о чем -то другим
Игорь А.: да я понял тебя ты
Максим Сагибгареев: же хочешь чтобы партнеры зарабатывали тоже да да да это же основная не должен они должны конкурировать ценой видишь то есть как бы я вот об этом думаю анализеры мы можем вообще потерять
Максим Сагибгареев: быть быть тех на которых даже не смотрят
Максим Сагибгареев: но
Игорь А.: мы из
Максим Сагибгареев: -за
Игорь А.: того что мы делали я вот помню опять опять же, смотри, тут вилка от двух конца, с одной стороны, да, да, есть там бесплатные какие -то продукты по типу, вот как я скидывал, да, вот
Игорь А.: дочке прям обязательно надо было там зарегистрироваться, все, теперь профориентация есть и государственная важная программа, все, мы теперь там будем проходить эти профориентации, я
Игорь А.: так понимаю. Есть платные всякие тоже онлайн -сервисы, я помню, что там медиальная цена была где -то 10 -15 тысяч, Потому что были кто -то, кто -то там за тысячу, за две тысячи делал
Игорь А.: профориентации онлайн. Были бесплатные, были те, кто там за двадцатку, за тридцатку делал. Были те, кто просто оставьте заявку. И вот тут, ну, понятное дело, что если мы идем в массовый
Игорь А.: сегмент, то, скорее всего, у нас будут цены медианы, близки к медианам. Но тогда будут ли, условно говоря,
Игорь А.: сейчас проблематику попробую выразить, будем ли мы интересны для партнеров с той точки зрения, что они будут зарабатывать 3 -5 тысяч, а не 30 -50 с одной продажи? ну
Максим Сагибгареев: смотрите то есть что я слышу да и то что говоришь это на самом деле важная проблематика во первых да во вторых здесь в любом случае опять возвращаемся к трем разным продуктом премиальный
Максим Сагибгареев: средний дешевый ну пока пока такая классификация тогда партнеры в премиальных пожалуйста и 50 можно зарабатывать и больше вот то что мы с чего мы и начали помните там полмиллиона это
Максим Сагибгареев: все эти крупные цены тогда
Максим Сагибгареев: это вопрос решается то тот продукт в том виде в котором он сейчас он ну
Максим Сагибгареев: наверное средний
Максим Сагибгареев: ну его его он легко продается образно там за 10 15 тысяч рублей легко продается то есть с легкостью на душе крутить его ну там вадим сейчас у нас просто есть более актуальна задача
Максим Сагибгареев: пристена перестраются на это докрутить хотя бы немножко но мы мы уже сделали полу версию полу обновления методологии не полноценная на полу и она уже хорошо там прям уже классно читается
Максим Сагибгареев: уже там ну то есть исходя из того что в тех же самых анкет ничего не меняли
Максим Сагибгареев: уже более когда есть табельно что ли меньше там страниц и более так профессионально вот искал термин более профессионально то есть не какие -то там лишние фразы мы просто критически
Максим Сагибгареев: проанализировали вадим там и не ронко просто уничтожила весь отчет как то что он вышел за рамки научности это неплохо то есть наша задача же какая чтобы у людей были гипотезы которые
Максим Сагибгареев: протестировать чтобы они понимали а есть разные карьеры надо потестить что -то посмотреть изучить вот поэтому если на кратчайшую дистанцию в том виде в котором есть то ну а смотри вы
Максим Сагибгареев: же здесь что то стира мы тестируем в принципе партнерский подход и как бы в принципе чтобы сам алгоритм и сам механизм работал и партнер на премиальные протер на непремиальные и ты
Максим Сагибгареев: вроде как универсальную схему сделал то есть может же быть такое что z y x это одна цена вообще
Игорь А.: может быть и они тогда не зарабатывает как
Максим Сагибгареев: бы в целом ну по сути их нет и все вот это просто мы продаем ну вот то есть как бы и по факту это вот схлапывается эти цены это наша цена сейчас а то что там небольшая дельта появляется
Максим Сагибгареев: но это как бы как раз таки то что вот эта универсальная система нам это позволяет а какая разница у кого -то может быть час стоит 50000 рублей например то есть сам парк сам эксперт
Максим Сагибгареев: говорит вот мой z например там 30 там я готов чтобы меня перепродавали за 40 или там это это получается что за цена р .с. вот давай ты мой консультант я эксперт супер английского языка
Максим Сагибгареев: я премиальный то есть что ты мне скажешь поставить на x р .с.
Игорь А.: смотри если у
Максим Сагибгареев: тебя
Игорь А.: премиальная аудитория которая тебе платит сейчас сколько ты за час получаешь ну
Максим Сагибгареев: допустим мой часто 30 тысяч рублей 30
Игорь А.: тысяч рублей сколько ты семье в месяц этой часов продаешь
Максим Сагибгареев: одной семье ну два два раза в месяц
Игорь А.: два раза в месяц 60 тысяч ну хорошая семья вроде бы когда значит скорее всего на x я бы вот рекомендовал
Максим Сагибгареев: З это вот моя цена, то, что я хочу получить, да, получается? З это
Игорь А.: компания получает.
Игорь А.: Смотри, Z это то, сколько получит компания, а в коридоре между Y и X может продать эксперт.
Максим Сагибгареев: Тут смотри, получается у нас тут небольшая, надо достроить. Да, я понял. Y
Игорь А.: минус Z или X минус Z это вот то, сколько получит
Максим Сагибгареев: эксперт. да я тебя слышу и я бы тут немножко поменял чуть -чуть доработал бы как бы саму систему партнерской еще одну итерацию сделал то есть чтобы еще бы не ровко сделала это следующий
Максим Сагибгареев: момент у нас есть платформа есть продукты платформы есть эксперты есть продукты экспертов услуги и продукты есть потенциальный эксперт который стал партнером и вот она вилка и тут может
Максим Сагибгареев: быть такое что как бы там же есть такая связка например если мы продаем часы эксперта на платформе просто вот напрямую кучок пришел на платформу за зашел видел прикольного профессора
Максим Сагибгареев: решил его купить час занятий платформа берет небольшую комиссию себе правильно но
Игорь А.: мы говорим о том, что платформа не берет наоборот комиссию. Так, секундочку,
Максим Сагибгареев: у
Игорь А.: меня, по -моему, был расписан этот. Вот способы заработка, способ рекомендации услуг эксперта. Вот он. Эксперт назначает бюджет привлечения S от базы S. То есть, например, вот ты как
Игорь А.: эксперт, который 30 тысяч рублей ставишь, ты говоришь за то, что я привлеку к тебе такого клиента, ты готов со мной поделиться 10 процентов или 20 процентов. Ты как эксперт сам назначаешь,
Игорь А.: сколько партнер получит, пригласив на твои услуги.
Максим Сагибгареев: По рекомендательной ссылке. Да.
Игорь А.: Да,
Максим Сагибгареев: хорошо. То есть
Вадим Х.: партнером является сама платформа в этом случае?
Максим Сагибгареев: Нет.
Максим Сагибгареев: Нет,
Игорь А.: это отдельный человек.
Максим Сагибгареев: Да. а если
Вадим Х.: парба платформа привлекает то ее партнерская партнерская
Максим Сагибгареев: да но еще есть и партнерская которой мы здесь не учитывая я бы хотел чтобы она была ну хотя бы как бы заложено нужно может равняться нулю формуле этот показатель должен быть то есть
Максим Сагибгареев: ты в любой в любой платформе который ты делаешь платформа выполняет услугу и создает сделку она за это создание сделки которая схлопнулась она имеет право получить выгоду свою каким
Максим Сагибгареев: -то процентом общей ценности сделки это логично адекватно рационально так
Игорь А.: ну давай вот плоды формулы рассмотрим которая здесь как раз есть касаемо платформы, сколько она может заработать. Вот берем 30000 те же и 10 процентов поставил эксперт, он готов отдавать.
Игорь А.: Что тогда получает, кто сколько получает?
Максим Сагибгареев: Мне
Игорь А.: кажется неправильную формула, но окей.
Максим Сагибгареев: Возможно, возможно.
Игорь А.: Давай попробуем докопаться до истины.
Игорь А.: Значит,
Игорь А.: единица минус b так b это доля рекомендателя в этом бюджете бюджет привлечения с от базы с смотри
Максим Сагибгареев: все правильно это правильно формула это когда только есть платформа и партнер продает что -то у нее я
Максим Сагибгареев: просто хотел расширить самую модель чтобы была платформа и ее продукты эксперт его продукцию и все вот и все что я хотел просто извини она например
Игорь А.: что там 30 процентов от дохода там партнера условно говоря получает платформа да или
Максим Сагибгареев: там ну ну примерно с моим угу кейсы ски покидать кейсы хочешь парочку прям вот прямой кейс просто есть платформа есть эксперт и пришел человек трафик трафика нашего зашел и купил у
Максим Сагибгареев: эксперта или мы как -нибудь направили там создали продажу клиента с экспертом соединили все то есть у него стоит например 3000 рублей час и мы продали за 4 или за 3 500 или за 3 300
Максим Сагибгареев: ну то есть эти разные кейсы говорю бывало что стоит 2 2000 вы продали за 3 500 вот то есть это наша наценка мы как бы с наценкой продали
Максим Сагибгареев: вот другой вариант может быть то что у нас нету какой -то гибкой наценки и мы просто там берем пять процентов за транзакцию за то что просто провели транзакцию то что она случилась
Максим Сагибгареев: то есть это не то что мы взяли комиссию просто традиционный расход который платит например сам эксперт то есть его цена 3 500 например указано и мы говорим что мы у тебя возьмем там
Максим Сагибгареев: не за 350 рублей вот чтобы случилось транзакцию там за совершение это сделал просто фи какой -то фикс фиксированный и туда не понравилась
Игорь А.: первая история которую ты сказал что например эксперт ставит свою стоимость например 3000 рублей а мы как платформа ставим на эти три тысячи рублей например 3500 я
Максим Сагибгареев: понимаю посмотри airbnb посмотри airbnb кейс он сейчас финальный у них кейс у них там тоже двухсторонняя платформа это же разные цены и они брали из тех из других в общем я к чему здесь
Максим Сагибгареев: просто то что ну как бы давайте проанализируем еще мы же не принимаешь из решения я
Максим Сагибгареев: не помню просто там цифр но это уход достаточно хороший кейс рациональности с кого кто что берет то есть сама платформа мы можем мы не берем например комиссии вот смотри вот он за 3500
Максим Сагибгареев: человек нам дает не понравился первый кейс
Игорь А.: ну да ты говоришь
Максим Сагибгареев: не
Игорь А.: не не мы берем с нашего конечного потребителя ну как как в принципе в рознице тоже все и заведено то есть marketplace например он прибавляет а нет он же из этой суммы но человеку нужно
Игорь А.: самому считать,
Максим Сагибгареев: вот
Игорь А.: человек хочет заработать, например, 10 тысяч рублей, и он понимает, что ему тогда нужно выставить это. Здесь немножко перевернутая система, но по сути человек хочет заработать 10 тысяч
Игорь А.: рублей, и поэтому на платформе цена его товара 14, потому что 4 сверху – это комиссия платформы, логистика, комиссии и так далее. 40%. Но
Максим Сагибгареев: считают обычно по -другому, ты правильно считаешь, считают неправильно считает вот так так я поставил там 60 фунтов а комиссия 30 процентов значит я получу вот столько -то ну вроде
Максим Сагибгареев: нормально да а ну дешево да давай поднимутся но в голове когда ты читаешь надо повыше сделать что если как бы вот тут играешь в обе стороны короче я тут просто саму систему и модель
Максим Сагибгареев: смотри я бы в детали не уходил пока на этой итерации то есть кейс какой первый кейс я сказал у нас есть разные слои как раз в этой цене так вот есть слой платформы он может быть 0 именно
Максим Сагибгареев: на оценке какой -то слой просто за транзакцию то что провели тоже должна быть учитываться маленькая цена то есть сама платформа за любую транзакцию собирается вы не важите порекомендовали
Максим Сагибгареев: не порекомендовали просто идет маленький фильм линда нет согласно до 3 3 с половиной
Игорь А.: процента например потому
Максим Сагибгареев: что на севаринг
Игорь А.: 07 лабора и 2 половины минимум онлайн как там это касса или как там что там ну
Максим Сагибгареев: да допустим такое и наша какая -то там 505 процента еще отчет какой -то фильм он там ты заказываешь еду 70 рублей этом заказу сама платформа берет то есть понятно что них еще есть какая
Максим Сагибгареев: -то цена цена образования не могут собирать еще с того кто иду эту продает так вот то есть есть как бы наценка есть просто транзакционный фи есть смотри есть товар самой платформы которые
Максим Сагибгареев: могут продавать партнеры у товара есть себестоимость это же как бы своя есть товар эксперта который может подавать платформа и могут подавать партнеры через эту платформу платформа
Максим Сагибгареев: свое все равно берет и тут еще есть формула который ты сделал она на 90 процентов закончен там нужно добавить еще 10 процентов платформенного и все и мы все кейсы то есть мы потом не
Максим Сагибгареев: буду возвращаться больше к этому всякие с обхвате просто игорь видимо исходил правильно
Максим Сагибгареев: ну как бы я не к тому что нам нужно это брать я к тому чтобы у нас формула была уже готова
Вадим Х.: до зубы заложено да понятно
Максим Сагибгареев: да цифра будет 0 например игорь если не хочет чтобы мы брали пока может быть 0
Максим Сагибгареев: бизнес как бы хочется чтобы если кто -то делает какое -то действие оно должно быть оплачен да
Игорь А.: за инфраструктуру платить надо ну типа
Максим Сагибгареев: того
Максим Сагибгареев: вот и то есть мы сейчас этот короткий комментарий можно внести сделать следующую версию сколько заняло это сделать то что ты сейчас ну я
Игорь А.: вчера начал он где -то часа полтора -два я поработал
Максим Сагибгареев: и
Игорь А.: сегодня я сел где -то в 930 в 12 вот я отправил
Максим Сагибгареев: хорошо у нас тебе предложение с вадимом вадим еще этого не знает но дай нам какой -нибудь то есть есть методология и параллельно мы запросим допустим тебе просто на на наши этой вашей
Максим Сагибгареев: системе закинем с ним ты сейчас закинешь у себя мы закинем здесь я наговорю как бы с водимом свой промт ты там возьмем эту транскрибацию которая вы сейчас будет и просто следующую версию
Максим Сагибгареев: сельщита улучшений учитывая вот этот добавочный контекст и можем потом ну как бы еще раз созвониться можем сегодня созвониться можем какие -то сейчас ключевые есть задачи которые надо
Максим Сагибгареев: прямо вот сейчас ответить чтобы вы могли что -то запустить потому что вилка цены она может же быть как бы позже решена или нет но смотри там вопросы которые тоже поднимаются сейчас
Максим Сагибгареев: что мне вылетает запустить компьютер
Максим Сагибгареев: У меня там был список
Игорь А.: вопросов, которые… Это что? Так, это путь клиента, путь покупателя…
Игорь А.: А, ну в принципе цель следующей встречи – продукты рынок, страна валюта, состав локальной версии, срок численный XYZ и проверяемая себестоимость. но я бы вот да я пока мы не дошли до
Игорь А.: этого лицензию может быть вообще просто так вторую идею пока мы ну чтобы туда не распылялись может быть лицензию пока бы не трогали
Игорь А.: это
Максим Сагибгареев: для кого лицей это более продажи да это вот как
Игорь А.: предложил саша вчера историю в кейсе наших конкурентов, где они покупают там лицензию по 6000 рублей и потом сами за свою любую цену продают. Да, но
Александр Бондаренко: подписка, имеется в виду подписка, инструмент.
Максим Сагибгареев: Да, помню.
Игорь А.: Да,
Максим Сагибгареев: что
Игорь А.: мне кажется проще первых партнеров привлечь, что вот вы продаете напрямую, потому что может быть такая агрессивная обратная связь что блин чуть такое мне что что -то зарабатывать надо
Игорь А.: еще заплатить ну вот эта история потом может работать да но как бы на начале я бы может быть
Максим Сагибгареев: смотрите вот такая такая мысль пришла вот допустим берем всех блогеров и мы все вот сейчас представьте с блогерами говорим да допустим привет блогер смотри вот классный продукт вам
Максим Сагибгареев: даем его бесплатно сделайте расскажите о нем на youtube там или в инстаграме еще где тот как вот блин были там вопросы проблемы пыталась вот помните все это время там пытаюсь выбрать
Максим Сагибгареев: эту школу короче нашла офигенное решение реально рекомендую ребят очень классные по ссылке проходите или к ним они и через меня вам скидку дадут вот ну там все классно и прекрасно почему
Максим Сагибгареев: что и как вот маша вот паша вот что им хотелось а вот на самом деле что им нужно и это прям ну магия то есть я заплатила 10 тысяч там или 15000 20 тысяч сколько там вот и блин прекрасно
Максим Сагибгареев: все сделали там за три часа я заполнил муж заполнил хотя муж с командировки был вот и сейчас сидим понимаем что будем пересматривать планы на университет и слава богу а то и дочь подтверждает
Максим Сагибгареев: и такая там довольно то что я сбуду есть бутерброд их довольны такая то что да наконец -то ура я так рада вот то есть смотрите вот есть просто кейс теперь дальше технически пошло то
Максим Сагибгареев: есть у нее есть аккаунт получается у нас системе у нее есть ссылка реферальная она где -то там добавлено вот сразу же там есть уже у нас какая -то цена точно и идет скидка от нее
Игорь А.: вот
Максим Сагибгареев: интуитивно я вижу этот кейс вы можете свои кейсы добавлять какие хотите то есть то же самое может быть с учителем английского он пишет мариван там помните по по английскому учились
Максим Сагибгареев: сами то есть вы были восьмом девятом классе не знаю выбрали предмет или нет вот я у меня мои классные партнеры друзья сделали сервис профориентационный я там небольшую копейку с этого
Максим Сагибгареев: заработаю но как бы вам сделаю скидку реальный классный продукт хорошее решение вот пожалуйста если нужно там маши то сделайте цена приемлемая рыночная ну и в голове у меня крутится
Максим Сагибгареев: тоже счета 20000 это где -то здесь 15 -25 15 -30 что -то вот тут где -то надо понять короче это вопрос на рассаж к тебе и в отдельную в один в общем к вам ребята как вам двоим и ну
Максим Сагибгареев: то есть все то есть вот смотрите большинство наших учителей часто это тысяч пять ну там от 3 до 5 в принципе они ведут большие пакеты то есть они реально работают у них есть те кто
Максим Сагибгареев: постоянно с ними работает то есть две -три продажи каждый из них может сделать вот просто вот там кто на профи в год давайте в год ну это моя гипотеза просто какая -то цифра анализа
Максим Сагибгареев: блогер какой -то ну если это большая аудитория и мы можем отследить он сам доверяет то что мы все четко проверяем не не знаю сколько может тысячу продаж делать там 10 тысяч продаж сделать
Максим Сагибгареев: вот дай бог но механизм вроде похож и как бы тут надо просто вот то что сейчас практичный как бы путь такой прагматичный вот прямо приклад вот прямо сейчас запустить можно и потом более
Максим Сагибгареев: такой выверенный весь это уже следующий этап то есть мы можем сейчас сделать первую версию такую вот чтобы не тормозилась не тормозить весь процесс и параллельно вести еще уточнение
Максим Сагибгареев: вот этого как бы ну интернационального запуска партнерской системы
Максим Сагибгареев: мои мысли закончились смотри у меня примерно так
Игорь А.: и написано по поводу инструменты учет разбора анализа 16 страница то есть как раз таки страница ссылка код с ценой к больше x контроля акции версия условия атрибуция независимый признак
Игорь А.: ну вот инструмент который нужно эта страница ссылка код с ценой
Максим Сагибгареев: я читаю то что ты здесь да у тебя написано какая -то страница у тебя на файле
Игорь А.: 16 страница
Максим Сагибгареев: вот этот момент инструменты учат посмотри чего здесь не хватает том что я говорю то что от меня чего не хватает да то есть по сути нужно понять в кабинете у нас блогер который или партнер
Максим Сагибгареев: наш до который хочет что -то перепродавать он в этой реферальной ссылке сам ставить цену или он никакого влияния на цену не оказывает вот тут это гипотеза и нужно ее как бы ну просто
Максим Сагибгареев: сделать две страницы и скинуть их вот нашим учителям английского давай заходи что видишь он такое я вижу вот реферальная система круто окей что тут а это моя реферальная система окей
Максим Сагибгареев: супер так это мой продукт окей это в это не мой продукт и я его продаю отлично ссылка ну то есть еще и мы проверяем как бы какое какая им версия нравится больше какой они хотят пользоваться
Игорь А.: и
Максим Сагибгареев: уже у тебя конкретные факты, что хочет партнер, ну, как бы, можем не проверять, вы можете это просто в голове проверить и сказать, Макс, все, точно запускаем вот такой -то сценарий.
Максим Сагибгареев: Если не пройдет, то, ну, как бы, какой -нибудь...
Максим Сагибгареев: Это
Игорь А.: была цель данной встречи, определить то, о чем ты говоришь. Вот это список того, что нам нужно для запуска. То есть это прям, ну, последняя страница, 16 -я, на ней весь список того,
Игорь А.: что нужно решить
Игорь А.: я думаю что на самом деле мы должны сами установить вот эту цену минимальную и рекомендуемую и в этом пороге пусть они сами уже рекомендуют
Максим Сагибгареев: непонятно делаешь итоги блогер сам поставить как увидит по своей аудитории правильно а может и 100000 поставить
Игорь А.: конечно
Максим Сагибгареев: но смотри то могут конфликты быть именно того качества то есть нашего обещания этой ценности которую они получат понимаешь то есть ну как бы ценность обещания и цену которую ты платишь
Максим Сагибгареев: и тут не должно быть тоже расхождение ну давайте сейчас все подумал то есть тебе нужно вилка да это ну вот наверно 35 15 хорошо а
Игорь А.: если это премиум клиент для него
Максим Сагибгареев: не может быть и но это премиум продукт еще
Игорь А.: массовый продукт ну да
Вадим Х.: если премиум продукты это дро это просто мы
Игорь А.: можем
Максим Сагибгареев: запустить другими на коне реальный смотри можем это запустить пока не премиальный потом другой запустить уже премиале даже тех же блогерам ребята короче вообще я в шоке что ребята творят
Максим Сагибгареев: буквально два месяца назад взяла у них одну такой простой продукт дешевый там 15 заплатили у меня же там трое детей двое детей они только что выпускает офигенно новое обновление как
Максим Сагибгареев: будто iphone и просто про версия и тут вообще колоссально и и и 100 и это есть и как бы зарплатная вилка и на будущее по это же тут проанализировали все короче ну я оплатила он конечно
Максим Сагибгареев: дороже стоит но блин будущее детей дороже особенно в это непонятное время полтинник заплатила 50 тысяч вот вам со скидкой будет 40 не я
Игорь А.: заплатила 150 со скидкой
Максим Сагибгареев: далее мир жива код 150 нет мы мы так не пойдем бро мы сейчас пойдем к следующему уровню премиальности мы просто свадим он ну блять не сможем это сделать ну это это сказочный подход
Максим Сагибгареев: ну не получается вы не сможете сделать мы не сделаем за 150 ту цену чтобы все были довольны мы за 5070 на разделаем следующий это раз у нас будет я не знаю вадим ты общался с даниилом
Максим Сагибгареев: по поводу его подхода чон там там нормальная база или нет
Вадим Х.: но мы вроде что
Максим Сагибгареев: говорили но он
Вадим Х.: пока еще и он дорабатывает ну
Максим Сагибгареев: тогда смотрим но тем более давайте эти версии он от бежене нужно сразу же продавать премиальный мы одновременно общую методику партнерки настраиваем он системно работала мы проверяем
Максим Сагибгареев: элементы вот там ценовая формула личный кабинет элемент последовательность что все цепляется но ошибки то дешевле совершать на дешевом пакете еще можно вернуть эти деньги и не будет
Максим Сагибгареев: так печально я
Игорь А.: в общем скажу свой страх по поводу блогеров продешевить
Максим Сагибгареев: их аудитории ну как ты это поймешь что ты продешевил очень много продаж будет ну мы на следующего блогера делаем другую цену не на следующего именно у этого блогера именно вы эта
Игорь А.: аудитория мы
Максим Сагибгареев: его закончим он выполнит все обязательства все кто купил купили это же цикл, он закроется. Ну, солнце зайдет.
Максим Сагибгареев: Ну ладно, хорошо. Пересмотрели. Не -не, нормальный вопрос. Правильно, бро, я просто тоже об этом думал уже.
Игорь А.: Смотри,
Максим Сагибгареев: я просто аналогию в другой продукт сейчас
Игорь А.: скажу, условно говоря, вот у меня за плечами сотни этих кладовок и, условно говоря, самое большое вот такое раздражение людей, блин, они же стоили по 250 тысяч, как так они сейчас могут
Игорь А.: стоить 700?
Игорь А.: Ну, типа, я, конечно, отшучивался, мол, так тут недалеко, всего два года назад вернитесь и купите, что вы.
Максим Сагибгареев: Ну, конечно. Нет, если посмотреть на последующие два года, то они и миллион будут, и два будет стоить. То есть, как бы тут вопрос... Либо подождите, я вам с удовольствием
Игорь А.: продам через два года за полтора до ну
Максим Сагибгареев: что такое не но смотри это же другой продукт тут актив который приносит себе доход а тут исследование которое позволяет себе предотвратить ошибки и
Игорь А.: как бы мы
Максим Сагибгареев: ну как бы приближаемся каждая версия у нас мы сейчас немножко ошибок только можем предотвратить ну там раскрыть чуть -чуть понимание больше насмотренности кстати термин саша это я у
Максим Сагибгареев: остырил короче насмотренно сочет огонь а у вадима они помнишь самодостаточность помнишь
Вадим Х.: короче когда
Максим Сагибгареев: документ делаешь разных версий финальную версию говорим у сделай чтобы этот документ был самодостаточный не было понятия что это было предыдущей версии были вот
Максим Сагибгареев: и тогда он делает зависимый ну короче насчет вилки
Максим Сагибгареев: я вам не говорили да у меня вышла то есть мы ошибки здесь убираем потом следующей версии запускаем вот сейчас запускаем ну как бы ту версию которую мы протестили в чай бенске и как
Максим Сагибгареев: бы в разных местах мы же консультации не делаем я консультации делают ценность добавочную консультация делает цену добавочной до 500 тысяч ну
Максим Сагибгареев: вот мы недавно продали 250 тысяч европейский регион ну то есть европу но тоже через предыдущего клиента то есть кто -то другой покупал до этого а сейчас если хотим продавать через блогеров
Максим Сагибгареев: ну то есть они вот нужно должны тоже представить как это продажи будет то есть люди которые в магазине продают в пятерочке или еще где -то в перекрестке они же там даже про полку договариваются
Максим Сагибгареев: на какой полке будет лежать как она будет лежать какая здесь проходимость как люди это будут брать то тоже самое блогер как он будет это продавать то есть я вот об этом тоже думаю ну
Игорь А.: конечно мы же в принципе там два вида либо первое мы просто даем ему задачу да и понимаем что его вводную информацию любом случае даем и мы понимаем что он заинтересован в том чтобы
Игорь А.: были продажи более большие возобраться продукты второй вариант Мы сами пишем шаблоны, например, тот же фрамбини, малина в шоколаде. То есть у них, это из таких кейсов, которые на слуху
Игорь А.: последний год, у них отдел по работе с блогерами, они сами пишут допустимые варианты сценариев. То есть что может быть в кадре. То есть, например, что обязательно должно быть? Обязательно
Игорь А.: должен быть продукт и обязательно его должны есть. все, все, что остальное там будет, это уже
Игорь А.: там, креативы разные.
Максим Сагибгареев: А почему так? Можете объяснить, Саш, можешь свое мнение сказать, и ты тоже скажи, почему именно вот они вот, именно эти два условия как критические выбрали для такого продукта?
Максим Сагибгареев: Парни?
Максим Сагибгареев: А мне вопрос? Я что -то просто не очень понял вопрос. Да,
Игорь А.: Саш. Не, я могу объяснить, то есть, свое мнение. Я так понял, ты Сашу хочешь послушать
Максим Сагибгареев: я обоих вас хотел мое мнение такое что замороженные ягоды дали что это такое да чем
Игорь А.: на фрамбине почему именно обязательно должны кушать не обязательно не важно что происходит
Максим Сагибгареев: вокруг вообще
Игорь А.: там может все что угодно то что это вызовет доверие сам блогер есть этот продукт он сам является потребителем все это безопасно
Максим Сагибгареев: вот то же самое то есть у нас получается человек должен на себе этот продукт про пробовать и рассказать об этом или
Максим Сагибгареев: себе на ребенке своем получается ну
Александр Бондаренко: это один вариант
Максим Сагибгареев: либо заход просто через историю вот как я вчерашний кейс рассказывал как тот чел блогер знакомый
Александр Бондаренко: рекламировал того чувака он не пробовал сам продукт он вообще не в курсе что там профориентация не профориентация но он просто через цепочку там 7 8 10 stories вот экранов просто рассказал
Александр Бондаренко: хорошо историю я заскринил у меня кстати сохранено это
Максим Сагибгареев: просто разруйте рассказал не учитывая он использовал просто прорекламировал да за вот
Вадим Х.: вот
Максим Сагибгареев: он просто я не говорю вам ничего ездила ли я на нем или не ездил да
Александр Бондаренко: вообще ничего вообще ничего он просто начал издалека что типа вот чел что -то вот учился там тра -та -та и вот потом создался он как -то умен заход был какой -то прикольный я уже забыл
Александр Бондаренко: если честно это уже давно было еще по моему в том уже году это было ну то есть но я такую углу ему люди прям этому блогеру начали писать нифига ты заход накрутил он прям ну из лички
Александр Бондаренко: скрины присылает типа вот это поворот типа что надевы в конце он такой типа а вот его профиль типа но есть хотите типа подпишитесь ну
Максим Сагибгареев: вот я вообще на обуви про волоса звучат рабочими ну хорошо да игорь какой еще сейчас остался у нас вопрос не закрыты давать давайте идти итеративно чтобы уже напустим ближайшее время
Максим Сагибгареев: тест запустить пилот как я говорил то есть у нас же есть учителя вот 22 пилот два человека запусти просто и все
Игорь А.: давай Давай я просто проговорю, да, нет или нет,
Максим Сагибгареев: почему. Давай, давай.
Игорь А.: Продукты рынок, значит, Россия, рубли, состав локальной версии, это вот то, что у нас сейчас есть профориентации, срок, ну, он автоматически это делается, численные X, Y, Z, ну вот
Игорь А.: если у тебя есть, у тебя хорошее ощущение там продукта, да, ну давай тогда. X это то, сколько наша компания может себе заработать Давай так, начнем с Z, это максимальная цена 35, хорошо,
Игорь А.: Y это 20, это то, сколько мы даем им возможность вот этого X, это 15. То есть минимум 15 мы зарабатываем, от 5 до 20 тысяч мы даже вот больше 50 % можем отдавать партнеру. Давай еще
Максим Сагибгареев: раз повторю, и ребята тоже сейчас повторите, и с чем вы согласны, с чем нет. То есть получается, Main Experts заберут 15 тысяч рублей, правильно? Да.
Максим Сагибгареев: рекомендованная цена по продаже партнера 2035
Игорь А.: минимальная 20 рекомендованная 35
Максим Сагибгареев: партнер меньше 20 не дает не должен продавать не должен
Игорь А.: то есть по
Максим Сагибгареев: сути он может мариване позвонить сказать смотрите классного 35000 дороговато так ну давайте я узнаю может быть они мне за 25 продадут или в моменте может сказать но мне есть скидка
Максим Сагибгареев: я могу за 25 и 5000 он нет он тогда 10 заработает до 10 а если за 20 продаст он 5 заработает
Игорь А.: ну
Максим Сагибгареев: то есть 35 это как бы может и не приставить
Игорь А.: да это рекомендуемая то есть там может она и выше быть не
Максим Сагибгареев: они же я хотел ниже 30 может
Игорь А.: и ниже до 30
Максим Сагибгареев: 20 15 то есть 15 мы получим 5 мы ему дадим либо 5 мы ему подадим это минимум да он получит всегда опять можно задать либо он может ожидать 15 либо
Игорь А.: 20 либо
Максим Сагибгареев: пинеси за 35
Игорь А.: ну
Максим Сагибгареев: тут я более интуитивно сейчас думаю то есть в целом 5000 за 15 беседы просто отправить кому -то ссылку вообще нормальная история
Александр Бондаренко: это
Максим Сагибгареев: еще больше попробовать и вопрос теперь как я это делаю мне нужно теперь зайти в личный аккаунт и могу я делать 15 ссылок на себя или это всегда одна ссылка у меня
Игорь А.: да смотри инструменты учет разработка аналитика страница ссылка код с ценой ты можешь делать любые коды с ценой с любой ценой в
Максим Сагибгареев: этом диапазоне
Игорь А.: между y и z
Максим Сагибгареев: этот страниц не индексирует больше
Вадим Х.: за это не сделать
Игорь А.: можешь
Максим Сагибгареев: рекомендованы
Игорь А.: можно
Игорь А.: можно y
Максим Сагибгареев: и выше давай
Игорь А.: так
Игорь А.: просто там будет просто цена если она выше чем z это там быть просто цена
Максим Сагибгареев: ну нам же нужно протестить чем и думаем то то есть как бы по логике вот давайте как я буду тестировать я учитель английского языка у меня есть фасап есть telegram вы со мной либо поговорили
Максим Сагибгареев: либо что либо у меня скинете страничку которая объясняет именно ее прочитать вот я учитель в этом ознакомить и все я пойму профориентация вот ее методика все и теперь я должен стать
Максим Сагибгареев: партнером я стал партнером чем не нужно вам дать и пани п что там должно быть
Игорь А.: Смотри, это вопрос условия и выплаты платежи и правовая проверка. Налоги и документы по выбранной стране. То есть, соответственно, у нас есть ИП Александр Бондаренко, на который уходят
Игорь А.: оплаты.
Игорь А.: применимость применяется у нас сроки расчетов я считаю что у нас какой там 14 дней до на возврат закон мы можем через 14 дней делать выплату по поводу эквайринг и валютные расходы естественно
Игорь А.: несет компания, поэтому мы говорим про 15 тысяч минимум, потому что налоги скорее всего берем тоже мы на себя. Но так как мы не являемся, как это называется, валютным агентом, забыл
Игорь А.: как это называется, мы можем, например, человек продал за 30, мы ему можем 15 тысяч перевести и это его задача заплатить ндфл 13 процентов то есть он у нас подписал оферту агентского
Игорь А.: договора галочкой и дальше а в ней прописано что мы за него не платим то
Игорь А.: есть мы не являемся его там как это
Максим Сагибгареев: проверить просто проверить начали лишь к проверьте потом можно юриста проверить то есть как бы я не против я мне кажется звучит логично все просто чтобы это на бумаге у нас была проверка
Максим Сагибгареев: следующей версии когда ты сделаешь чтобы это тоже учитывалось у нас есть ну даже вот родион общались он уже давно ждет он готов у них там есть инстаграм и они там все сделали тесты
Максим Сагибгареев: то есть в принципе как бы у них уже если понимание не сами прошли она может это выложить везде и как бы посмотреть как среагирует аудитория все можно переговорить вот так же взять у
Максим Сагибгареев: него все данные там у них есть все есть вот и проверить просто вот как будто бы она там блогер сказать что должно быть можем отправить и там видео записать приедет кто -то запишется
Максим Сагибгареев: видео выложит она может на телефон это сделать как бы вот эти все вот этапы то есть это виз взаимодействие ну тут уже получается как блогер вот
Игорь А.: смотри вот здесь есть продажа и бренд основатель плюс маркетинг вот продажа и бренд Кто продает? Продает, например, партнер, принимает оплату, компания Main Experts, ИП Александра Бондаренко,
Игорь А.: отвечает семье, там автоматически платформа отвечает семье. То есть дальше вся коммуникация идет платформы, степень публичного упоминания Main Experts. тут, как по мне,
Игорь А.: отдаем на пожелания партнера. То есть он может говорить название компании, может не говорить, просто говорить, там классные ребята. Вот как я Таня, там классные ребята, я ей вообще,
Игорь А.: ну то есть ей все равно было, как эти ребята называются. То есть ей главное, чтобы порекомендовали классный продукт.
Игорь А.: Границы личного предложения. Здесь я считаю, что на усмотрение партнера. то есть он может рекомендовать как угодно в любой форме не порочащий честь и достоинство компании мне
Максим Сагибгареев: очень понравилось знаете ли вы какой -то способ заработать в интернете но не крипто да я просто отвечаю я комментирую все да
Игорь А.: да еще авиасейл конечно и сам мемщики крутые
Вадим Х.: вопросами ребят есть позволите смотрите если компания main experts сама продает продукт сама вот
Игорь А.: на
Вадим Х.: профориентация какой какая цена установлена на
Игорь А.: подходу
Максим Сагибгареев: никакой ребят ответ по ходу что этот продукт который мы так продаем у нас не будет системе
Максим Сагибгареев: а мне кажется
Игорь А.: 35 или
Игорь А.: типа сами думать
Максим Сагибгареев: а они могут не подешевле чем мы даже продать ну и слава богу да да да мы
Вадим Х.: можем
Игорь А.: выше р р р ц поставить 50000 мы можем
Максим Сагибгареев: поставить хватит говорить это может давайте сейчас то что 50 тысяч,
Игорь А.: мне кажется, нам надо поставить 50 тысяч, а партнеры сами будут уже…
Игорь А.: У них же даже на лендинге сразу будет 50 зачеркнуто, 35 или 20, ну то есть уже будет зачеркнутая цена.
Максим Сагибгареев: Плюс, плюс, плюс. Да, если они будут выставлять цену выше, чем 50, то
Вадим Х.: этой зачеркнутой цены не
Игорь А.: будет, там просто будет вот такая -то цена. Ну то
Вадим Х.: есть, а как они продают выше, если человек зайдет и увидит у нас на платформе 50?
Максим Сагибгареев: А как он зайдет и увидит?
Александр Бондаренко: Так, подожди, в чем вопрос? Ну, увидит он выше 50,
Максим Сагибгареев: и
Александр Бондаренко: что? Не понял.
Максим Сагибгареев: Ну, другой продукт может?
Вадим Х.: Нет. Ну, тот же даже,
Игорь А.: ну, зайдет, увидит дороже. У партнера дешевле. В общем, вопрос
Максим Сагибгареев: не понял. Не -не -не, если у партнера
Игорь А.: дороже, если партнер продаст дороже.
Максим Сагибгареев: Нет, есть сценарий, Саша, когда партнер, например, ставит 70, а у нас на сайте 50.
Александр Бондаренко: Я считаю, что нужно этим пренебречь.
Максим Сагибгареев: Потому что, опять же, вот есть кейс, который уже продают, у них 6 тысяч себестоимость. То есть за 6 тысяч может пройти
Александр Бондаренко: человек. Я вижу, что люди на своем канале продают за 50. За 50 и за 80. И как бы никто не парится этим вопросом. Я предлагаю
Максим Сагибгареев: тоже сейчас этим вопросом не париться. Я единственное бы пометку поставил, юридически разобрать этот кейс. И все.
Максим Сагибгареев: в целом согласен потому что ну крайний случай чем мы не делаем продукта с нашей платформы только партнерские продажи идет правильно можем же так можем потом
Максим Сагибгареев: можем сделать как ты сказал там 35 они там могут ниже делать продавать можем отлично звучит логично на сайт зашел 50 а как это дать через себя ну мы просто с ними этот ну как я
Игорь А.: партнер платформы я платлю
Максим Сагибгареев: партнер платформы мне там они со студентами помогают там еще что -то или там
Игорь А.: да я у них
Максим Сагибгареев: провожу уроки
Игорь А.: то есть я
Игорь А.: являюсь частью экосистемы поэтому через меня можно дешевле
Максим Сагибгареев: супер слушай почему то 70 то я у них вижу 50 ну
Максим Сагибгареев: может они обновили довольцы на скипка какая -то когда
Игорь А.: мы
Максим Сагибгареев: и вижу но возможно это
Игорь А.: не не тот пакет потому что я тебе же еще буду услуги оказывать
Максим Сагибгареев: ничего не мешает
Александр Бондаренко: тоже от себя давать какую -то дуб консультацию вот ну да
Максим Сагибгареев: там же просто техническое исполнение как бы тут тебе же консультация важно вот и со мной бушку
Максим Сагибгареев: кстати ребят на ведь какая прикольная тема вот эксперт начинает продавать за 20 мы ему знаете что я думаю сделать нам нужен верх поставить нужно поставить цену выше которой нельзя
Максим Сагибгареев: вадим об этом думает я обязательно прям что я вижу причем я ем хот -дог где пришел inside это не просто
Вадим Х.: почему
Максим Сагибгареев: зачем нужна верхняя планка
Александр Бондаренко: ну просто так давай
Максим Сагибгареев: до конца добью мысль смотрите можно прикольно сделать то есть у нас есть полностью план обучения по нашей профориентации ты проходишь этот план и получаешь на сертификат ну там как
Максим Сагибгареев: тестирование так далее сертификат получил теперь ты можешь делать консультации все
Максим Сагибгареев: теперь ты можешь продавать этот продукт ну максимальная цена плюс консультация это первый момент как раз то что ты сейчас сказал ты же не просто покупаешь продукты же еще со мной больше
Максим Сагибгареев: это все общаться вот тогда он он имеет право это делать второй момент ну цена и ценность то есть может быть такое что бля я не знаю 670 это конечно пиздец разница ну бывает и выше разница
Максим Сагибгареев: согласен просто
Вадим Х.: негатив он будет копиться блогеру пофиг то нам не пофиг вот речь да
Максим Сагибгареев: не будет он копиться вот
Александр Бондаренко: мое мнение они вообще вот знать не знают они увидели
Максим Сагибгареев: этого блогера
Александр Бондаренко: ну пошли но заказали у него на купили умели
Максим Сагибгареев: вообще до лампочки миллион поставил давай вот сценарий миллион рублей и и расколся покупатель хренины новое мы
Александр Бондаренко: получили
Максим Сагибгареев: с этого 20000 30
Вадим Х.: 20 он получил
Максим Сагибгареев: 980 тысяч и
Вадим Х.: и п
Максим Сагибгареев: на и п к
Игорь А.: мы еще на вага заплатили 60 тысяч миллиона мы
Максим Сагибгареев: заплатить
Вадим Х.: но здесь еще тут еще вот вопрос
Максим Сагибгареев: если мы платим то это не
Александр Бондаренко: очень удобно если он принял на себя этот миллион рублей нам заплатил вот эти минималку 15 это еще проще ну то есть тут тогда
Максим Сагибгареев: уж лучше вот такой вариант что он на себя пусть
Александр Бондаренко: принимает
Вадим Х.: не
Максим Сагибгареев: все согласятся и не все тебе переведут обратно
Александр Бондаренко: нет смотрите в смысле не все не переведут если он не переводит то и уж пакет не активируется клиент платит ему он говорит вот переводи мне там на тиньков на т -банк до 20000 например
Александр Бондаренко: чтобы ему открыть для этого пользователя, ему нужно сперва заплатить нам, а потом уже
Максим Сагибгареев: скинуть
Александр Бондаренко: ссылку этому клиенту на прохождение.
Максим Сагибгареев: Ребят, а почему трехглавый дракон — это отрицательный персонаж?
Максим Сагибгареев: В смысле?
Максим Сагибгареев: Ну, в сказках. Почему он является того, кого пытаются убить? Так он же съедал все время,
Вадим Х.: деревню съел, еще кого -то там съел.
Максим Сагибгареев: Ну, тут он, конечно, да, ошибся, я согласен. Но в целом, что я заметил, то что у нас сейчас четыре головы это пипец как круто то есть по сути что ты говоришь саш то что он партнер оплачивается
Максим Сагибгареев: своей карты как спонсор клиента да
Александр Бондаренко: и
Максим Сагибгареев: потом скидывает ссылку уже на прохождение просто тут то он кидает ссылку на страницу и там оплата идет как будто клиент заходит ты говоришь немножко другой workflow продажи который
Максим Сагибгареев: имеет место быть
Александр Бондаренко: ими а это
Максим Сагибгареев: быть но в этом подход котором твоем там максимальной цены может не быть соглашусь который мы сейчас прорабатываем там должна согласен с тобой точно точно согласен уставлям принять на
Максим Сагибгареев: это даст согласен за
Александр Бондаренко: согласен
Максим Сагибгареев: продуктивно что вам скажу мне нравится я уже спокоен высоков всего тут открыли блин реально рабочая схема еще
Вадим Х.: у меня второй вопрос был по поводу первое если сам продает компания сама вроде ответили данном возможно либо так либо так либо вообще не продает ли продает допустим по рэйр цепочку
Вадим Х.: а второй вопрос не был такой по поводу учителей вот смотрите учителя которые например преподают на тетр фуля они
Игорь А.: ставят свою цену
Вадим Х.: какую они хотят учили стоит там 30 фунтов например платформа ставит сама рассчитывает ну по своим критериям цену по своей методике и ставит цену на него там 55 фунтов и их это не устраивало
Вадим Х.: потому что он говорит что за 55 я уже получаюсь там совсем как бы ну да достаточно дорогим меня мало берут
Вадим Х.: вот хрен получает 30 и то есть как бы вот этот момент такой то что мне это не нравится это был такой негатив вот соответственно когда мы говорили по поводу краски наценок и нацелок
Вадим Х.: мы говорим смотри ты приходишь ставишь говоришь на цену ты ее и получаешь все ее и клиент платит и платишь а мы монетизируемся по -другому ну допустим здесь может быть какая -то либо
Вадим Х.: комиссия небольшая либо какая -то другая монетизация виде подпискам и так далее вот если же мы продаем урок этот сервис партнеров то он получается сразу ну
Вадим Х.: то есть как как это работает где его цена которую он получит учитывая то что он как учитель хочет больше зарабатывать может хочет больше зарабатывать он не хочет удовольствоваться минимальной
Вадим Х.: ценой которая вот ему платить и все то есть ну вот не знаю я здесь пока не очень вижу как как должно быть правильно может быть но
Максим Сагибгареев: смотри ты про портфа или ты про другой продукт говоришь нет
Вадим Х.: нет я про час занятий учителя которому
Игорь А.: привлекли умерть
Максим Сагибгареев: умерть и предложения чтобы ты тоже подготовил короткий такой с лишкой ответ как раз такой вопрос ты задай этот вопрос подготовь ответ ну что очень важный здесь но немножко другого продукта
Максим Сагибгареев: касается и мы как раз к следующей версии когда придем ну ты нам это дашь все и лишь просто давайте попробовали бы вопросы которые у нас будет который будет стоять
Вадим Х.: да и саш вот
Максим Сагибгареев: ты говоришь про эту верну любой вверх ты можешь все как бы отдельно звучит давайте сейчас пока без нее вот хотя бы на первой итерации что мы
Александр Бондаренко: могу могу конечно ну давайте давайте
Максим Сагибгареев: без нее то есть мне нравится идея чтобы другие другие зарабатывать а хоть он зарабатывать и реального кофе давайте зарабатывать довольны быть еще рекомендовать
Максим Сагибгареев: но
Александр Бондаренко: какая у нас сейчас задача
Максим Сагибгареев: мы хотим протестить что сама система работает что все ватам ссылочки работать что кабинет работает партнера ну то что там запустил первый запуск запустить 12 через партнера тоже все
Максим Сагибгареев: ссылки работают там два тричок купила платежи все прошли они все сделали им отчеты отправились, нагрузка нормальная, ничего не упало, прошли 14 дней или сколько -то дней, мы сделали
Максим Сагибгареев: выплаты.
Максим Сагибгареев: Вот я бы вот это все, чтобы пилотное было прям отработано. И потом уже добавим усложнение, которое ты говоришь, Саш, и потом на другой продукт перейдем, как ты говоришь, Вадим. И то,
Максим Сагибгареев: что я там искаю, все остальное начало с самого начала, это тоже можно потом перенести.
Александр Бондаренко: Хорошо.
Максим Сагибгареев: Хорошо.
Игорь А.: Смотрите, вот эти два
Максим Сагибгареев: флоу они расписаны в
Игорь А.: картах процессов вот тот когда деньги принимает партнер он на странице 11 когда принимает по рекомендации клиент приходит сразу принимает main experts он на странице 10 то есть эти
Игорь А.: два флоу они в принципе расписаны то есть что выполняет партнер на каком этапе что получает семья при этом и какая ответственность в main expense когда у партнера покупает там деньги
Игорь А.: да там как идут и условия выполняется как когда к нам приходят вот смотрите
Максим Сагибгареев: все круто это я вижу ее перед глазами тут один момент только я бы еще сделал один уровень детализации то есть еще делается одна карта слоем ниже по иерархии то есть больше деталей больше
Максим Сагибгареев: точности больше стрелок если вложенность вот в каждом виде запрос что это значит там это это это то есть разбить еще тогда мы можем увидеть потенциальные риски ошибки и еще что то просто
Максим Сагибгареев: это да ну как бы это верхнеуровневая карта то будет низ ниже нижний уровень тогда мы можем вот этот нюанс учесть потому что сейчас этот нюанс как бы тут не то есть видит запрос передает
Максим Сагибгареев: ссылку
Максим Сагибгареев: покупают рекомендации и
Максим Сагибгареев: технически тоже хочется как то чтобы надо будет потом через ребят пропустить но вот не знаю я помню был этот dropbox вроде бы dropbox или как он там
Игорь А.: был такой сервис может
Игорь А.: существует да
Максим Сагибгареев: и я помню их они рекомендовали тебе давали эти гигабайты за рекомендацию вот и там прям все ну ты реально хочет бесплатно год у тебя что были эти
Вадим Х.: там ссылки кидаешь просто всем подряд
Максим Сагибгареев: или сараешь себе дополнительные аккаунты на другие и мэйлы ну или такое делаешь еще что -то ну любом случае как бы это понятно что систему можно играть с ней но они все равно хорошо
Максим Сагибгареев: выросли то есть у них была вирусности люди оставались потом и платили продолжали платить и те платежи которые у них были они покрывали их себестоимость развития команду всех всех содержали
Максим Сагибгареев: на три есть успех коммерческий успех то есть сейчас задача в принципе такая стоит чтобы все что на и п будет приходить она покрывала все российские расходы наш
Максим Сагибгареев: смотрите время на партнерку будет тратиться то есть ты будешь каждым партнером разговаривать или нет сейчас пилотно да можно с каждым потом наверное думаю надо как -то пробовать уже
Максим Сагибгареев: не с каждым что
Максим Сагибгареев: еще какие еще мысли ну выплаты чтобы до автоматически были как
Максим Сагибгареев: мы сейчас поймем удобно лёг как вот мы поймем что все ок да говорит ты правильно еще говорили я хочу сказать что для партнера ты заходишь выбираешь продукт и
Игорь А.: у тебя удобно в вилку минимальные максимальной цены и и может им по звукам крутить там туда -сюда например хорошо
Максим Сагибгареев: вопрос вопрос аж тебе тоже игорь тоже смотрите я блогер я все покрутил сделал цены 35 такое все так выходные сейчас там я не знаю день учителя все закидываем так ребята день учителя
Максим Сагибгареев: короче всем учителям всем там вот по профориентация всем родителям все круто делайте покупайте по ссылке переходите скидка будет вам вот через какое -то время он ставит еще одну ссылку
Максим Сагибгареев: делать но уже другую цену а это все еще активно
Максим Сагибгареев: нормально
Максим Сагибгареев: нормально вообще
Максим Сагибгареев: это история
Игорь А.: она постоянная я поэтому говорю что бывает какая -то часть просит либо возврат либо компенсацию какую
Максим Сагибгареев: -то но это чем закрывается что на тот момент бы была такая вам были вам даны такие условия сейчас условия другие если там возможны условия окей вы можете получить возврат денег пойти
Максим Сагибгареев: там купить но мы естественно партнеру говорим и братан у тебя тут как бы не бьется ты уж либо на брата не сиди на двух стульях да да вроде нормально не знаю на первом приближении я
Максим Сагибгареев: пока конкретику начинаю видеть уже
Максим Сагибгареев: какие дальнейшие действия какие дальнейшие шаги самые важные критичные саш как ты видишь и игорь как ты видишь
Максим Сагибгареев: но на ближай я партнер не особо много мыслей одну мысль скажи самую критическую важную надо опылять надо опылять нужно как можно
Александр Бондаренко: больше с большими количеством людей соприкоснуться и предложить
Максим Сагибгареев: ну если брать вот ближайшие пять дней сколько людей ты думаешь будет нормально ну
Александр Бондаренко: чтобы так вот лично персонализировано ну вот минимум 10 вот прям лично персонализировано так про какие -то ссылки в чат и и там про что -то еще там я молчу там невозможно
Максим Сагибгареев: 10 партнеров на этой неделе проверить протестить
Александр Бондаренко: надо ну
Александр Бондаренко: хоть хотя бы соприкоснуться и как -то вот не просто типа вкинул он прочитал и ничего ничего не ответил а имеется ввиду вот по взаимодействовать то есть как
Максим Сагибгареев: такое предложение игорь сделаешь потому что в google доксу себя просто нам ссылку кинь типа excel там имя фамилия данные и так далее я тебе дам свои какие -то контакты кто может быть
Максим Сагибгареев: партнеры там 23 вадим посмотри может кто -то в грузии там есть учителей кого -то просто потестить
Вадим Х.: вот
Максим Сагибгареев: что еще саш ну тебе такой же вопрос может кто -то есть потенциально там подруга бы мамы брата жениха которая преподает французский
Максим Сагибгареев: язык и новолетов
Александр Бондаренко: у меня помладший контингент у меня пока до
Максим Сагибгареев: 10 лет что нити ну ну хорошо тогда можно по -другому сделать у нас есть таблица вот в профи там психологи игорь с ними тоже поаккуратнее потому что они психологи ну то есть тут как
Максим Сагибгареев: бы все может быть от них не знаю что ожидать вот можно найти учителей как бы таких у меня есть учителя которые активно учителя но они не блогеры то есть тут как бы мира две категории
Максим Сагибгареев: да есть надо протестить которые типа блогеры небольшой базы подписчиков может быть они могут быть узконаправленные предприниматели правильно ведь
Александр Бондаренко: надо почему нет ведь
Максим Сагибгареев: 100 просто дети под дети и подростки у всех есть то есть получается 2 2 или 3 когорты то есть чисто блогеры такие медийные чуваки которые там все рассказывают есть какие -то предприниматели
Максим Сагибгареев: которые о своем продукте рассказывают или там выкладывают красивые картинки там не знаю путешественник там отели продает отели выкладывают там еду еду готовить там вот и учителя есть
Максим Сагибгареев: правильно у меня есть такой ученик который идет свой по биологии прикольным ему там не знаю сколько нас на 1500 заработал со все время вот ну денис есть тоже игре все это тебе говорю
Максим Сагибгареев: еще ну то есть все для тебя сейчас и выбирать что нужно как нужно мы тебя поддерживаем скажи только что надо от нас еще
Максим Сагибгареев: слушай но я перед тем как звонить до базу это важно собрать я перед тем как звонить контактировать с людьми все -таки хотел бы но иметь какие -то материалы которые им скинуть вот встреча
Максим Сагибгареев: прошла не такие но окей скиньте ссылку да вот так а может чтобы сразу уже с ними и запартнерится то есть и материалы и чтобы технически все работало да да да да ну то есть хотя бы mvp
Максим Сагибгареев: было технически что мы завели вот статус партнера может
Игорь А.: быть даже пока что без
Игорь А.: экзаменации без выдачи сертификатом и потом да да конечно
Вадим Х.: конечно то
Максим Сагибгареев: есть было у них был вот этот инструмент формирования их быстрой ссылки
Игорь А.: как вот я саша
Максим Сагибгареев: написал сашскими
Игорь А.: land он мне коп скинул все я отправил там оплатили да то есть вот чтобы потенциального партнера было максимально был максимально легкий flow и достаточность инструментов для отправки
Игорь А.: материалов тогда тебе
Максим Сагибгареев: обратный вопрос тебе обратный вопрос можешь пожалуйста сделать flow вот там ты уже сделал теперь конкретный flow и списком прям сколько тебе нужно материалов и каких какое какие цели
Максим Сагибгареев: для чего они нужны что они должны быть не готова и как бы как раз таки и они будут с путя сочетаться ставим flow на этом флоу какой -то материал на этом такое то может на этом все три
Максим Сагибгареев: или там все пять и вот у тебя достаточно flow достаточно детализированный и материалы подготовим себе потом мы это отдаем все программистам они быстро делают и у
Максим Сагибгареев: них же тоже не ронг они тоже там вайб кодят им тоже нужна спецификация спецификации готовишь
Игорь А.: вот это
Максим Сагибгареев: спецификация то что ты сейчас сделал
Вадим Х.: сейчас
Максим Сагибгареев: секунду у меня вроде было это
Игорь А.: либо либо сейчас
Игорь А.: секундочку я к точке предложения вот смотрите инструменты цены и страны вот мне это было странице 1 продуктовая основа локальное предложение надежная фиксация каждой продажи
Максим Сагибгареев: вот
Игорь А.: компонент личная страница ссылка показывает конкретные продукты цену поддерживает к там в общем код определяет предложение для автора рекомендации ну в общем проверка мрц понятно фиксация
Игорь А.: заказа сохраняет все это и возможность возврата отмены если она наступает
Игорь А.: ну как это
Максим Сагибгареев: вроде не все это flow да здесь больше функция как бы
Игорь А.: но это то что да должно быть у парни
Максим Сагибгареев: на самом ну да элемент
Вадим Х.: карточка
Максим Сагибгареев: партнера паспорт партнера там у меня есть путь партнера
Игорь А.: опять же но так первая итерация хотя бы это хорошо куда ему идти разобран и попал есть тоже начиная к ростике на 9 странице подключения партнера то есть как его этап знакомства этап
Игорь А.: модели условий принимает условия и готовность создает все свои материалы для того чтобы отправлять ссылку то есть первое приближение уже тоже есть в этом файле
Максим Сагибгареев: это прекрасно было я прям более чем уверен что ты все круто сделал я вижу то что у тебя уже хорошо я просто к чему сделать уже вторую терацию которая будет потом посмотреть еще еще
Максим Сагибгареев: нужно да то есть потому что здесь получается три стороны то есть мы партнеры клиентup платформа платию партнеры есть и клиент клиенту что -то нужно будет от партнера партнеры что -то
Максим Сагибгареев: нужно будет от нас партнера должна быть вся инфраструктура которым будет пользоваться и которым он может передать клиенту у партнера должно быть понимание тоже процессов и карта его
Максим Сагибгареев: процесса и он тоже наглядно все это видит для себя я партнер продаю и по цене он тоже наглядно видит смотрите вот пример вы продали этот пакет по такой -то цене заработали 5000 то есть
Максим Сагибгареев: такая презентация своему объясняет
Игорь А.: вот
Максим Сагибгареев: и потом может быть страничка примеров как можно это все сделать если вы там через чат там потому что и рок все это может нарисовать конкретный кейс там вы общаетесь с родителем ребенка
Максим Сагибгареев: вот вы там через блок вы там в инстаграме или еще где -то вы там на ютюбе запишите расскажите вот это просто как пример примера кейсов все смотрит у него фантазия узкая мы ее расширили
Максим Сагибгареев: у него страхи мы их убрали у него непонимание как дальше действовать мы ему показали как теперь он вероятно что он ошибется низкая вероятность то что конверсия случится высокая ну
Максим Сагибгареев: в общем да это первое приближение большинство этих вопросов которые ты задаешь здесь уже они отвечены и и по флоу и повод смотри партнер семья а сейчас секунду от валька ничего пусть
Максим Сагибгареев: даже отключено будет я бы запомнил в голове держу картинку у меня есть ну ребята можешь включить и конечно оплата здесь я все вижу да вот это брат вы если идти все есть
Игорь А.: да то есть в
Максим Сагибгареев: воздухе возврата здесь вроде нет
Максим Сагибгареев: возврат
Игорь А.: есть сейчас я покажу где он это по flow непосредственно путь партнера его заработка
Игорь А.: я где -то это делал а это вот инструмент это в самом инструменте внутри есть функция возврата либо отмена
Максим Сагибгареев: точно ну супер ну там надо ее просто распространить час сквозное чтобы она в процессе попала и например вот здесь
Игорь А.: когда клиент приходит по рекомендации вот сюда тоже можно ну
Максим Сагибгареев: да просто если возвраты будут ручными и мы их не обсудим то как бы мы потом просто здесь вот он как бы можно
Игорь А.: сказать что завершает расчет учитывает корректировки выплачивает а вот здесь возврат и есть то есть но как бы это один из сценариев
Максим Сагибгареев: период выплат и я думаю нам нужно будет показать какие -то успешные кейсы еще то что вот ну там такой -то учитель в таком -то городе помогает родителям получает дополнительно получила
Максим Сагибгареев: от нас дополнительно в этом месяце там 30 тысяч рублей
Игорь А.: лигала
Максим Сагибгареев: чтобы тут не было никакого наеба
Игорь А.: вот смотри
Максим Сагибгареев: даже есть
Игорь А.: экономика и панель результата показываем выгоду партнера умный расчет период
Игорь А.: положены средняя цена и дельта результат после расходов расчеты с платформой лицензию
Максим Сагибгареев: 14
Игорь А.: знаешь
Максим Сагибгареев: комментарии почти 14 странице ну именно потом когда документам которые мы применяем уже прикладные такие то все эти формулы нужно ну во -первых понятно ну то есть менее абстрактных
Максим Сагибгареев: примерами описать чтобы понимание партнера было прям ну как трехлетний ребенок, ему все понятно. Слэш
Игорь А.: как он, dash ten
Максим Сагибгареев: level или как
Игорь А.: он там в этом, в чат GPT.
Игорь А.: И он пишет понятным текстом для ребенка 10 лет.
Максим Сагибгареев: Просто, чтобы это было применимо
Александр Бондаренко: человечески. Не знаю уж там как.
Максим Сагибгареев: Да, ну это вот, типа, слэш стик,
Игорь А.: и он тебе ответ выдает стикерами, вот как в этом, на доске можно, на холсте.
Игорь А.: да
Максим Сагибгареев: ребята давайте еще еще какие вопросы у нас остались по
Александр Бондаренко: партнерке у меня еще одна прям тема прям на
Максим Сагибгареев: три минуты от вас на про эту тему или про другую какую -то про другую
Александр Бондаренко: ну тогда надо
Максим Сагибгареев: заканчивать мне кажется уже все хватит чтобы следующий раз сделать игорь
Максим Сагибгареев: давайте закругляться уже прям интенсивно и круто все обсудили кучу информацию прям я Я уже сам буду что -то делать.
Максим Сагибгареев: Супер.